James is with us in Los Angeles
hi James how are you I'm doing Thursday
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'm just being honest
with you and I'm curious what you would
say about our situation and I've heard
you talk about it a lot but I wanted to
know if it would make sense to show my
house not the rest of my debt which is
all student whoa whoa
how much is your student loan debt my
wife and I combined amongst the three
degrees is ninety one thousand okay and
with three degrees I hope you have a
really nice income what's your household
income right now unfortunately it's
combined at fifty thousand about two
years ago I left my hundred thousand
dollar job to start my own business I
know wasn't the smartest thing to do but
at the time it was it was more of a
passion thing and kind of just feeling
at my limit and my business is doing
great
it is debt-free and growing but the
income there I I don't know exactly when
I can say I'm going to substantially
started taking home enough to put into
this 91,000 the way I would need you to
have it done and somewhere under three
years do you like your home we do we
like it but our plan is to sell it and
right now I reply to some some her plan
is to sell it want to upgrade more to
like our you know what would be more a
little bit sizable for a family I mean
we we would be willing to live in this
house if that's what it meant living
here is expensive I mean it's hard to
find any houses under four or five
hundred thousand sure my house right now
I have a 304 on it and so the hard part
is that our mortgage and everything is
well over the 25 percent being that I
left the career that I had initially
went buying it so does your wife work
outside the home yeah she works and
she's our staple so it's not work
full-time at the company and she
Muhammad Nora oh she works for you
pretty much he's the one who makes me be
able to grow my business and then
aside note I do I'm part of leaving was
to take an opportunity to train
competitively I don't have ever heard
about the CrossFit Games but it's the
limits of thing in life I I'm getting to
that point at 29 years old round they
have a few years left to try to enjoy
this part and see if I can make it and
so that's part of like our situation
which is why we want to attack that and
I I do regret not taking care of it when
I have the income because I've learned
how much flexibility can buy you
opportunity and I didn't take care of
that that's the way we should have Wow
and selling your house you have $90,000
in equity yeah I so in order to in order
to grow your business and be a CrossFit
champion you're going to be a renter
yeah and is that what we're saying is
that is that the conclusion yeah and
it's one of the things where it's even
ours ever I mean I can't do this
business I could fit on holes with
training and being competitive I think
you put enough income on hold for a
while buddy
I mean you you've got a family to take
care of here and you got $90,000 where
the crappy decisions you made before
today so we don't need to be taking on
any more hobbies and another extra my
mother-in-law is gifting us with 35,000
next month and that was just asking to
go right into my wife for them and pay
all our student loans off so that would
take the 91 down to in the end of 50 55
and I'm curious to see if we should try
to fight through that and keep the house
and that's kind of been our my view I
think yeah I think you fight through it
and keep the house and let's do what it
takes to grow your business and you've
got a you know balance your physical
fitness hobby with the needs of your
family and you know what's primary if
you had to list things down what's the
most important thing what's the second
most important thing was the third most
important thing in your life down the
list it CrossFit should not be the top
they should be it should be your wife
you know your walk with God those kinds
of things should be at the top taking
care of your family should be at the top
and I'm not saying you shouldn't be the
CrossFit thing I mean I got friends that
do you know Ironman and and I've trained
for half marathons and full marathons I
know the time that that takes and that's
a lot less than what you're committing
because you're very serious at your
level so you know you've just got to
work this through and and think it out
you know at you know when you're 40
years old when you're 50 years old what
are you gonna be glad you did and what
are you gonna be glad you didn't do and
but it sounds to me like with that gift
coming that's a nice piece of
information late in the conversation
that that I'm probably gonna try to
continue to grow your business and you
know it may be that you need to run your
business without your wife and she needs
to go into the marketplace and make some
money rather than working for you for
free you're both working for you you
didn't just reduce one income you'd
reduce two incomes both in this business
so you know that might be a way we can
get your income household income up if
she goes and gets a job and you run the
business without her and because you got
enough degrees floating around there for
sure so yeah I'm gonna try to get my
income up keep the house and then use
the house later on as the way we move up
to a better house that you want to do
later on after you get some of these
other goals behind you hey thanks for
the call